foreign
hey Dr John massive fan of yours your
book redefining anxiety changed my life
so thank you so much I appreciate that
man I got a new follow-up on anxiety
coming out man I'm excited to get in
your hands that'd be great
oh awesome what's up dude great
yeah so uh I just recently got engaged
um we moved into an apartment together
um we've always had a really great
relationship
um I love her so much you know but it's
always felt like we're just past that
best friend's threshold in some ways
um even though we are super attracted to
each other and we are intimate you know
I don't know the right way I guess to
get to that next step
I'm not suit so if we were just hanging
out just you and me I just we I just met
you and we're hanging out
it sounds like a guy who really wants
her to like him but she doesn't but I
don't think that's the case here so give
me some more some more
uh Clarity here
yeah there's more to it you know she's
always
I guess you know had trouble opening up
um physically
um she I think she has a lot of anxiety
about it
um and it's always limited our intimacy
Beyond a certain point
um it's been like five years that way
and then to throw another variable into
all of it you know I've become a lot
more religious
um and I found God accepted Jesus and
you know I know I shouldn't have sex
before marriage anyway so I'm really
honestly fine on waiting on that but I
don't know how to know that this will
change once we get married because
that's sort of what she's assured me on
um I just want to respect her you know
respect my religion
and I don't know how to achieve all of
those things moving forward I guess
I think our culture is obsessed
psychopathologically
we're obsessed with and this is
religious and non-religious
intimacy equals intercourse
and I just reject that I don't think
that's accurate I think everybody
intimacy means something different to
everybody and we can draw some big
generalized buckets here but with the
way you just described it what I'm
hearing is
um a woman who
is struggling with trust and is
struggling with feeling safe and my
guess is it her her challenges with
intimacy are are not just physical she
probably didn't tell you everything
that's going on maybe even keep secrets
from you or just says Ah it's okay am I
am I onto something or no
I I think you are I mean and I think I'm
I'm the blame too you know when I try to
talk about it sometimes I I think I get
a little frustrated and then I can see
her withdrawal if it shuts down yeah
yeah so the
anytime somebody says they've got
anxiety about a thing
um anxiety is not the issue there what
the issue is is that your body has
detected something that's not safe
Stephen poor just calls it uh
neuroseption your body is scanning the
environment it has found something
that's not safe
for any number of reasons you remind her
of an old boyfriend you remind her of
somebody that hurt her you remind her
you're the picture of the guy that's
pushing her past her boundaries for five
freaking years and she's tired of it but
she also loves you also doesn't have any
self look whatever the story may be it
could be a thousand different stories
and so I less want to figure out I mean
you
this is a broad generalized statement
here okay and so be nice to me on the
internet yeah I'm painting with a broad
brush here
I'm finding in more and more couples
that I talk to more and more men and
women that I talk to individually for
some particularly men intimacy is about
sex it's about connectivity it's about
desire and fantasy and when you feel
deeply desired enough that somebody is
revealing themselves to you then you can
tell them about the things that scare
you and the things that hurt you and the
things that you dream about like I want
to live in this kind of house I wanna
have this kind of job someday
and again broad General brush
it works opposite for women
I need to know what you're thinking I
need to know you're with me I need you
to hear me I need you to know that we're
on the same page and that is the gateway
to intimacy
to my body does that make sense
yeah and then when you don't have that
people go to war because you're both
using the word intimacy you're both
using the words we just want to get
closer you're both using the words love
and they look like completely different
things to each other
and then one of you gets mad one of you
shuts down and then you end up getting
engaged because that's going to solve it
and then you end up you see what I'm
saying and you end up in this dance and
that's when you get four or five or six
or seven years later when he is really
frustrated one of you is completely shut
down one of you's gone back to old roles
and one of you starts having a
conversation with somebody at work and
they light you up for the first time in
a long time
yeah I think you've 100 nailed it there
um you know and and I think
you know from her perspective it
probably is that she's shut down and
that for me I'm I'm just completely
completely frustrated you know yeah yeah
um so she's not here and so I don't want
to spend a lot of time digging into what
she's thinking and why she's thinking it
my concern is that you
a don't feel like her lover you feel
like her best friend
um you have the safety part down but you
don't have the romance part down and
for you this is about a series of
actions
it's a series of steps she needs to do
things she needs to do to show herself
and you're starting to be concerned
about
down the road and what I don't even know
what down the road is we don't have to
go into it but is that are you like
wondering like is she gonna be wild is
she gonna like do all the crazy things
I've got in my head and all things I've
Seen On TV like
or is it just not boring or like what
are you worried about in the future
well I I want to know I guess that we
can have a normal intimate relationship
that does include sex one day because
she's just so closed up you know it
doesn't have to be wild it doesn't have
to be like that I guess I just I want
some Assurance somehow
that it will happen and then she assures
me all the time that it will and you
know that she's not holding back for any
religious reason or any other reason
it's just that you know she's never
really done that with anyone you know so
it's it's just a really odd situation I
guess it's not odd at all
there's that's a young woman who's tired
of being pressured
so she shuts down
and
you have to decide
if pressure pressure pressure pressure
pressure
slowly wearing somebody down
that's how you want to come into
connection with somebody
I do not want that for my life
yeah absolutely not and also I think
I've been doing this are you able to
find connection and Intimacy in a much
broader picture
in the way she thinks about you and
helps out and the way she
reaches out and says how can I love you
better and you reach out right it's so
much more than just intercourse man I
was so obsessed with it intercourse is
awesome
but it's not the end-all be-all of
intimacy right
um it's about both and I don't want to
just but you're the only one on the
phone right so if you are both here I'd
be having a conversation with both of
you so I don't want to sound like I'm
just kicking you while you're down but
um
I don't think I don't see this changing
even after you get married that's not
some magic switch because you have not
created a context where she feels safe
opening up to you and I'm not just
talking about sexually I'm talking about
all the way across the board
okay and so if I'm you a couple things I
would do number one
I would start and go first and say I'm
looking back over five years and I
realized I've created a world where I'm
on offense all the time and you're on
defense all the time
I've created a world where for whatever
reason
my presence the things are that that I
have identified that bring me
connectivity intimacy those things shut
you down they scare you and I think as a
couple we've got to call that out before
we get married
and I don't feel comfortable moving into
a long-term relationship when you don't
feel safe with me and I don't feel
comfortable moving into a relationship
long term
where I don't know how to make you feel
safe
and again it's not just you got to feel
safe so that you can have sex that's not
it sex is off the table for me right now
this is a much bigger deal right
um I would recommend reading both of you
reading Come As You Are by Emily
nagotsky and both of you reading the
five love languages now the five love
languages doesn't have a lot of science
or anything behind it that I know of
maybe it does but more it gives you a it
gives you a framework I think there's
way more than five ways to communicate
but it gives you a framework for having
the same discussion
instead of talking past each other
does that make sense you all live
together yeah
yeah we're in an apartment together
um and yeah usually that accelerates if
a couple in your situation usually if
they move in together
um it makes everything heightened and on
fire because you're stu you thought that
by moving in together I would feel more
connected and less lonely and you
actually feel more lonely in a crowded
room
yeah I mean that that 100 true it's it's
just gotten worse but I'm willing to do
the things you said because I mean I
don't I don't even like the way that I
feel like I am in these situations if
that makes sense yeah
I think the more that you
and again dude I I'm saying this with
all just due respect and love okay the
more you view her body as something
that's gonna fix you
or the more that if she would just do
these things then you would fill in the
blank
the more you're putting pressure you're
putting weight on her that she simply
can't carry
no person can carry that there's no such
thing as I complete you that whole thing
was a that was just a Tom Cruise movie
right right and here's the here's the
Paradox you can't do Life by yourself
either
and so I've got to have somebody with me
so that I can repel off the edge
not
um I've gotta have somebody with me or I
can't breathe
see what I'm saying and I know it gets
all messy and esoteric I have you all
gone to couples counseling yet
no we haven't okay I can't think of
anybody I've talked to today that needs
to go more than you guys do
and the conversation is not how to be
more sexually connected or how to deal
with intimacy that's not it at all
I think you go first and you say I need
to learn how to make my wife feel safe
around me because for the last five
years I have not done a good job she
knows I love her she knows I think she's
beautiful I that she's the she's the
greatest in the world
but she has her body doesn't feel safe
around me and I don't know what it is
but I want to I want to heal that I want
to be better about that
and that's the language I would take
into it
okay now that that helps a lot I I
didn't I never thought of framing it
that way anytime she says I'm feeling
anxious about just replace that word
anxious with your body's trying to tell
you you're not safe
and by the way sometimes your body's lie
sometimes they don't tell the truth
sometimes she doesn't feel safer on you
because of something somebody else did a
long time ago
right right but it at least let's go
there
why is her body saying this guy's not
safe we we can't trust this guy why is
everybody saying
I gotta shut down I gotta hide I gotta
shut down I gotta hide why
why is that
and what part of you is bringing that on
what part of you is setting is just
pouring gasoline on that fire one part
of that is completely totally you right
and it may be nothing to do with you but
y'all are in this thing together okay so
get those two books Come As You Are by
Emily nigotsky
um it's a it's the best book on sex I've
read and it gives a couple's common
language it's actually written for women
but I think it's a great book for men to
read too
um it's not a faith-based book or
anything like that but it's it's it's
outstanding and the five level languages
book will just give you all a common set
of words to use together
um
that can maybe begin to give you all a
path and then you need to go call it
marriage counselor we're seeking safety
here my brother thank you for being open
man